hi there well it's what is it now it's
almost one o'clock here in the afternoon
I haven't started studying Korean yet
other than that I had a 15 minute
conversation with Julia and I cut it
short because uh because I was busy you
know I got up this morning to watch the
hockey game canada beat Sweden Sweden
didn't put up much of a fight rather
unfortunate that one of their better
players was disqualified just before
game time because of some decision on
some you know medical component of some
allergy drug that he's been taking for
years rather bad situation I feel sorry
for the Swedes although I can't
understand that Swedish organization
wouldn't have found out just exactly
what medications all of their players
are taking and check to make sure that
none of these medications contain banned
substances my son Mark played
international hockey for Canada and the
organization was all over them all the
time about whatever medication they were
taking so and there's a lot of whining
in the Swedish press up and reading
online but some responsibility surely
has to be with the Swedish organization
it's a pity that we didn't see Russia
and Canada in the final that would have
been a real cliffhanger but there you go
so then so it's been a slow day and I
also wanted to talk a little bit about
the situation that Ukraine so I had my
15 minute conversation with my Korean
tutor then I have a half an hour
discussion with Afghani in st.
Petersburg and a half an hour discussion
with Elena who lives in the Ukraine near
Kiev and the most interesting to me was
the discussion with Elena and yesterday
I sort of expressed some concern that i
had about the influence of these right
wing and militant nationalist groups
amongst the protesters the people
involved in the Maidan demonstrations in
the Ukraine the perspective from Elena
was quite different she sort of said
that these my Don type demonstrations
have been taking place all over the
Ukraine she lives in the central Ukraine
and rather than they were sooner to
start in the West and perhaps more
active there they have been
somewhat everywhere and while the these
organizations like the right sector are
the best organized and the most militant
where she lives it's been ordinary
people and she is actually quite
positive she feels this is a real
opportunity for the Ukraine to get a
fresh start she feels that in the past
the orange revolution and and all these
things have never basically changed the
system people change the president
changes but basically it's been a system
of a lot of presidential control a lot
of corruption and not a very well
functioning society and people are tired
of it the bulk of the people are tired
of it and she went into great detail
about how Yanukovych controlled what
people were able to say and express and
the degree of corruption they went on
and people were well aware of it
although more information is coming out
now about just how much corruption there
was the mansion and magnificent grounds
that Yanukovych had in Kiev and of
course the corruption of his son and all
this kind of stuff and so that she is at
least I mean obviously concern for the
future but feels that it's an
opportunity to do something she doesn't
think that a lot of people are going to
vote for Svoboda and for these
right-wing groups she's hopeful that a
candidate will come forward who is
considered somewhat neutral and
acceptable to majority of people but the
big thing she thinks is that the that
the power will come back to the
Parliament and that it won't be such a
sort of a an arbitrary system as they've
been living under so that's a little bit
more encouraging than some of the
impressions that I got yesterday from
discovering you know the nature of some
of these forces so really it's a matter
of waiting to see what happens obviously
she was also saying that the you know
the European Union in the u.s. it said
they were going to help in some way I
think Russia is waiting to see since
they backed Yanukovych they're going to
wait and see just who what the
government is there and hopefully the
government there will make an effort to
in fences with Russia she was telling me
that the leader of the right sector has
been saying that the relations with
Russia are extremely important and that
they want to develop those relationships
too and obviously the ideal scenario for
the Ukraine is to have very you know
sound relations with the European Union
and with Russia there's no way they can
operate with an unfriendly Russia you
know at the back door so that was kind
of just to provide some balance from the
sort of sense of concern about the
influence of right-wing elements that I
haven't brought up yesterday some people
have asked me to provide you know
someone asked me to provide Russian
subtitles I can't do that no ya heard ya
mogu a privilege coverage in Moscow
palouse ki kya yeah Chingo Guardians
Annie Meyer's res commun uh-oh shipshiyo
is Jerry oka risky cesky not my pocket
lainnya it at artists over Crimea both
ships ago nervously element data so so
so Buddha Yelich Ukraine say yes
elicited kak receivable yet yes which is
a shiet a problem actory doesn't receive
some crazy yeah gavel ranches that
Saddam son a mighty TSA is Crimea in
Anna Radha stow Yanukovych who Jay yeah
yeah la presidenta stow it a chance la
crania it a chance Ravi versa normally
obsessed well normally Parliament ski
politics key system potamus toe ananya
dooma dooma store Eddie probably silly
probably a limited control of our
control your rage SID wat say
store Ludi bullet Garza watch Nibali
centricity personage poker on Amelia on
an attack not yet ya tozhe the agenda is
Sheetal yet tion style clay aiken yesh
nuh nuh Sonya next to cry gracia travels
in Bosnia obey Tom history chest nickel
today a economy cesky Paula watching
Sydney rubbish alien if totally Mia
cleaner doesn't make sure was motion
still at receive at machinist therapy
Ebola know you need Buddha Yelich
sous-titre put the motor pattern with
Toby nyonya dreaming okay spasiba Enya a
mad know a fact is such as yeah thousand
up yet zenyatta car is gone